"Whoever does not jump is Viktor Orban" they
chant,
Hungary's prime minister, a pariah here among
this coalition of opposition.
All day sunday, thousands - from the greens
to the far-right - were united in anger.
Fed up with what they say is their government's
creeping authoritarianism.
In the thick of the smoke bombs, tear gas
and clashes - desperate voices plead for calm.
"Do not throw!
Do not throw!
Why are you throwing?"
Others pointed the finger at the police.
"I want to say that these protesters are here
for you too.
For you and you and you, for all of you."
The outrage was sparked by a rowdy parliamentary
session last week.
With Viktor Orban's government taking over
control of a judicial system that has until
now been independent.
and weakened employment rights - described
as a "slave law" by critics.
For many, this 7th constitutional change in
as many years under Orban was the last straw.
"Well, I'd like to have a democracy here.
I'd like to live in a country where I can
freely decide on what I can do and no decisions
are made above my head."
"We have unfortunately reached the point when
the government interferes with almost every
bit of people's everyday life; in cultural
administration, labour and healthcare."
The outcry is piling pressure on Hungary'
government.
And puts its controversial leader on a collision
course, not just with the European Union,
but with his own people.